well the last minute announcement by the
provincial government to return to a
modified step two of the reopening plan
has left many parents and business
owners baffled by the sudden decision
and frustrated by the mixed messages
that sentiment is the driving force
behind this op-ed published in the
toronto sun with a headline that reads
as you can see ontarians are locked down
again and that it's unacceptable
and the author post media columnist
anthony fury joins us now anthony we
appreciate you joining us so let's talk
about your headline you say it is
unacceptable why is that
well you know angie for the past 24
hours i have heard the frustrations of
so many people who say hold on a second
we were fine to go along with previous
lockdowns but now we've been vaccinated
some of us have been triple vaccinated
we followed all the rules we postponed
seeing family members we downloaded that
qr code app so we could comply with the
vaccine passport our children many of
them have been vaccinated and now here
we are facing a variant that public
health ontario has now confirmed is
significantly milder and yet we feel
like we're back to square one and i
think a lot of people are just very
frustrated with that and they're saying
we've had enough
so when you look at schools and
businesses referring to schools for
example they've said all along they are
last to close first to open
last week the chief medical officer of
health dr kieran moore said he saw no
reason to make changes to the student's
planned return and that was to be on
monday so what happened between then and
now
well that's a really good question
because there's been a lot of nuance and
context that's often missed with the
conversation around kids in covid
pediatric infectious diseases experts
have said uh one of the silver linings
that there can be one of this whole
pandemic is they found that covet 19 has
proven to be less severe than influenza
when it comes to kids
we've got tony fauci and others stepping
forward to say that uh the reported rise
in pediatric hospitalizations that's not
really what's going on that so much of
this is actually incidental
hospitalizations meaning kids are coming
in for broken arms just happening to
test positive for asymptomatic proven
and in ontario the reporting on cases in
schools isn't really what it looks like
because when we report these numbers
cases in schools people take that to
mean transmission of the virus happening
in school but as dr kieran moore has
affirmed as dr eileen davila as dr
lawrence loebs they have all maintained
the actual in-class transmission has
been a very small percentage of that
number so there's a lot of data that
that could be assuring parents uh if it
got out there more that i don't think
we're hearing amplified enough so let's
talk about the politics behind the
scenes to really lead to this decision
of course and also looking ahead to five
months from now and how much of an
impact that will have with the
provincial election what are your
thoughts
yeah that's a very good question and
unfortunately i think politics is
playing a role in this i think one
appreciates that teachers unions
certainly uh want to look out for the
safety and best interests of the people
they represent but at the same time when
you saw various teachers unions uh
posting online the past few days that
they did want to push for delayed school
reopenings they would have hashtags that
said vote for it out or what have you
sort of political sloganeering and one
goes well hold on a second are we
actually talking exclusively about uh
concerns around covet 19 and
transmission in the classroom or are we
also talking about a bit of a political
play going on here and i think if
there's an element of the latter going
on and it appears there is that's uh
incredibly unfortunate i think parents
would be right to be pretty frustrated
that uh perhaps part of the delay in
their kids returning to school has been
exacerbated by political reasons all
right so we don't have a lot of time but
you you've heard the other argument they
say look we can't just
you know miraculously create
all these healthcare workers to deal
with a possible search not to mention
the the current situation what are your
thoughts on that
yeah i think we've been hearing this for
a long time and i would encourage people
to look at the ontario sunshine list
where they say that we have hundreds of
people who are paid uh 200 300 400 600
000 a year to effectively manage the
hospital system i'm not talking about
our frontline heroes i'm talking about
back office administrators who are not
doctors and we've thrown hundreds of
billions of dollars at covet 19 and
people are saying hold on a second two
years into this we're still told that
children
who are not at serious risk of covet 19
have to lose out and be denied uh in
class schooling because you can't find a
way to manage the system such that you
can't manage a search capacity that
right now is about 240 persons in icu
and that's very frustrating to people
well certainly a lot of frustration and
confusion we appreciate this anthony
fury a columnist with post media always
a pleasure sir thank you
thank you